you got sober in prison
yeah 1968 i came out of the pen well i
came out of the hole and uh
and i just
asked god to let me die with dignity and
i'll say his name every day and i'll do
whatever i can for my fellow inmate and
i got kicked out of the hole and uh
so i started doing i just started i
became chairman of aaa i became a inmate
social catalyst and i just started
doing whatever i could for my fellow
inmate i said inmate because i never
thought i was getting out of prison you
know
and uh the parole board mad dog madden
that's his real name
said uh said give you know what we're
going to give you a reward
give you um
30 days get out of here bring us back a
life sentence i'll never forget that
said it so calmly bring us back a life
sentence in other words i had a 10-year
top so
that's all they had me for so i
i signed coming back and i remember i
was
that's it now i got to learn how to be a
nice guy
it's such a good deal man were you like
not like
were you shooting up like while you were
boxing and like you would go and like
would you ever go hide a box or
i did everything yeah i shot
i stopped shot heroin and boxed you know
i drank in a box
uh in prison
yeah i drank pruno which is the worst
thing in the world
if anybody out there drank pruno you're
a damn alcoholic okay
so funny when i go to prisons and i talk
about alcoholism and
drugs that says you know what let me
tell you something
if you guys in here anybody here drinks
bruno you're an alcoholic okay because
if you gotta drink that stuff
it's your [ __ ] up homes and worst
tasting [ __ ] in the world and uh buddy
will get you drunk
so that's i talked about that and i i
fought loaded i fought a load on heroin
and
you know i fought drunk
got hit up pretty good but it's all
right
yeah yeah and this um the hole you're
talking about when you got out of the
hole was that like a solitary yeah you
were in solitary for like three months
or something like that
ain't nothing my my cousin did 16 years
gilbert
you know he went uh
he went to uh
the hole for stabbing the guard stayed
16 years
you know so
and and in my time you know like when
you stayed in a hole a month two months
three month warming that's a long time
18 months mario stood four years my
assistant the guy that i met in san
quentin
uh
when i was doing bloody and blood out he
was a resident he refuses to be called
an inmate i was a resident
[Laughter]
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is it's completely multimedia
legitimately x-rated there's legal
waivers all over the venue because i'm
actually worried about getting sued and
i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass so get to my
[ __ ] website stevo.com and get your
tickets man especially with this movie
coming out dude they're all gonna sell
dude so hurry up while you can get seats